I love the days when you don't get out
of beds don't leave a mess though no
crumbs in the bed no I always like to
lay a towel down
hello everyone I'm Philippa Sue I'm Luke
Bryce and I'm SEMA Liu and we're the
cast of One True Love and we are going
to play the game hot or not otherwise
known as
fire Emoji or the letter x
I think we're all fire emoji
so we're gonna hear about some things
that people do while in relationships
and we're gonna have a conversation
about whether we are into it we're not
into it because we love judging people
[Music]
I'm gonna do one of these
whoa Tana depends I'm a big I'm a big
hand holder I love holding hands very
cute I love stealing kisses you know
like I love a little when I think no
one's looking I'll sneak one in there
sneak one on the hand but like not like
not like eating each other's faces you
know in the middle of the street sort of
thing it's like I don't know within
within reason yes oh look at us yeah
yeah we're so happy no never that but we
really love each other and the world has
just disappeared
yeah that's cute that's hot
[Music]
I mean that is not for me
that really isn't he is yeah that's I
mean that is a that is okay I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this I'm gonna put
this away there you go I'm gonna go time
for real talk
I think it's that's just someone's life
and it's I think there's so many
different circumstances where that could
occur
back into judgment mode
[Music]
oh I think that's a lot full I think
it's really sweet love a love letter
come on we're doing a romance novel
movie yes love letters professions of
Love Grand romantic gestures I mean any
sort of moment for someone to express
their enthusiasm for their person I
think but like in a letter like
especially if it's like a handwritten
letter you've taken the time to think
about it write it out send it I mean
that just shows that you went the extra
mile I think incorporated into Loveland
is just maybe even little notes as well
misses that are found around the house
just stuff like that a Post-It note yeah
that's good left out on the counter
[Music]
yeah I like things in that place there's
something really sexy about building
your home like building and not not like
laying brick but like building your home
doing the laundry together changing the
bed like it's very wholesome to care
about your stuff and your space yeah
sign of a good team I need someone who's
like willing to
have a clean space absolutely very
important
cleaning is so hot
[Music]
yeah yeah
imagine if you said no absolutely
yeah it's lovely being you know
expressive and fun and silly vulnerable
vulnerable yes with those things all of
those things
[Music]
same yeah that's what no no
I don't think it's spontaneous all I
know is all I'm thinking about when I
see Tick-Tock dances is the person who's
standing 50 feet away from them being
like what are they doing over there I
don't understand tick tocks
there's Boomers right here it's
Millennials it's Millennials
um I mean I like watching sometimes I
like watching the dances I can't lie I
think this isn't this there you go there
you go
[Music]
breakfast in bed breakfast in bed lunch
in bed
get up and do it all again the next day
I I love the days when you don't get out
of bed don't leave a mess though no
crumbs in the bed no I always like to
lay a towel down
a little picked it's like a little
picnic on your own bed yeah
yeah love it yeah
[Music]
yeah
snookum Bears too long too long babe
good one babe
um I one of my one of my best friends
and his wife they call each other bugs
that's very sweet yeah yeah
[Music]
sure turn up that fire Baby Cooking with
someone's nice as well in terms of the
the teamwork of it
you know I'll do this and I'll get the
oven and yeah I like the kind of the
dance of it I love that it's a cooking
class because I'm not a great cook so
yeah you're learning nice to have the
instructions
well if you want to see something that
you are going to love make sure you
watch one true loves with these guys who
are both
[Music]